we're calling it pulling back the
curtain where we dig deep to expose the
real reason for some of the more
disturbing developments in American
politics and culture today and our first
installment focuses on USAID and US aid
to persecuted minorities in the Middle
East these programs are meant to benefit
Christians and other minorities in the
region but the benefits have largely
gone to those of the Muslim faith our
government says Iraqi and Syrian
Christians are undergoing a genocide so
why aren't they getting the help they
need just last week Vice President Mike
Pence seemed to take a big step in the
right direction our fellow Christians
and all who are persecuted in the Middle
East should not have to rely on
multinational institutions when America
can help them directly and tonight it is
my privilege to announce that president
Trump has ordered the State Department
to stop funding ineffective relief
efforts at the United Nations and from
this day forward America will provide
support directly to persecuted
communities through USAID but now USAID
a deeply entrenched government
bureaucracy seems to be dragging its
feet on the Trump pensa Genda a
spokesperson told Fox News that the next
step is a workshop on proposals and that
it won't take place until January by the
way that's well into the frigid winter
months when these populations are most
vulnerable and the agency's announcement
said nothing about cutting off funding
to the UN as pence originally declared
so why are parts of the government
defying the president's orders joining
us now for reaction from Houston is
congressman Bryan babban a Republican
from Texas and here in Washington Nina
che an international human rights lawyer
for over 30 years and former Obama State
Department official David Tafari
who just returned from a refugee camp in
Iraq congressman let's start with you on
this because when I first heard about
this I thought this can't be I think you
have vice president Pence announcing
that we are now going to be sending aid
directly to the people who need it most
we're not going to go
through this UN bureaucracy and then
what okay this is the same thing this is
what we call the deep state this is you
at US aid these are this is the same
organization that has teamed up with
George Soros and countries like
Macedonia and when the Vice President is
speaking for the President as well says
that there's going to be a big change in
USA that will go directly to these
persecuted minorities like Christians
there and then when the when something
when the spokesman comes out for not
only USA but also State Department and
basically pushes back against the
administration I've got a real real
problem with that and the the
populations of Christians have fallen in
the in these countries they're in Syria
and Iraq by almost eighty percent and
the UN camps are filled with Isis refu
infiltrators and and basically
Christians do not go into these UN camps
from whence come our refugees into our
country and so this is why is it's so
important for the tax dollars of the
United States to go directly to these
persecuted groups rather than through
the corrupt and the obviously an
incompetent UN this is per it seems
purposeful I mean this isn't the first
time USAID has gotten itself into some
hot water David you just came back from
this camp and there's so many poignant
stories and so much suffering and that
comes out of these places but tell us
what we are getting wrong do you think
in this narrative so far sure so I was
in Iraq about a month ago and I went to
Kirkuk and other places across in
northern Iraq two weeks after I got back
the iranian-backed Shia militias and
Iraqi army went into Kirkuk and took
back her cook which for the last few
years has been peaceful and secure held
by the Kurdish Peshmerga they displaced
158 thousand people many of which are
religious minorities there's now reports
from a Christian town telescope in Iraq
that the Shia militia
are actually persecuting Christians
there the problem in Iraq is not going
to be solved by USAID or by the UN it
needs to be solved by the US military
and the State Department and by putting
pressure on Baghdad to pull back the
Iraqi army and pull back the Shiite
militias this is a security problem it's
not something that either the UN or a
USAID can solve Nina you've been
studying this and following this and
advocating for Christians in the Middle
East I think more than anyone out there
been killing the other one but tell us
why this issue is so incredibly
important for people watching us tonight
what they might not know about what's
going yeah well there's hundreds of
thousands of Christians and Yazidis
these are survivors of Isis genocide now
there's an inflection point now because
the us-led coalition has liberated their
home towns and they want to go home this
is an Iraq where northern Iraq Mosul
mostly as Mosul but that's any Sunni
town now Sunni City but Nineveh province
is where the Christians and Yazidis both
live and they're desperate to go back
they are very depressed they've been in
displaced centers for this is the fourth
winter they've been streaming out of the
region this place is going to be devoid
of they're going to be erased so
that'll get me back to pens yeah the
vice president so gave a very decisive
speech for Swift help for immediate help
and with money are we talking about well
it's you know we're probably talking
about tens of millions of dollars could
really help these people go back to
their homes and and again it goes to the
UN and then what happens if it goes to
the UN let me give a city doesn't want
to do let me cite some examples there's
the town of telescope this is the town
which Navy SEAL Charles Keating gave the
ultimate sacrifice to liberate this from
Isis and there are Christians who have
gone back there and they want to live
there and the UN projects for them with
US aid are fake we have remain there
photographs that been taken the outside
wall of a girl's school has been painted
nicely with you
stamp all over it inside we have
photographs of rubble it's it's really
unusable building this is a fake project
this is the list and there are magic
that are yes there are many project you
know there's the town of Taos guys this
is a place where it used to be a
Christian town the UN claims it's doing
projects for the Christians they are
happening well the UN has moved Isis
families into the stop congressman what
can you do
what will Congress do to ensure that US
taxpayer dollars are being used in the
most effective way to help the most
desperate people we know we know
Christians have been left out of the of
the refugee a game here in the United
States for too long trump's balance that
out quite a bit this year but what will
you and Congress do well if Congress
needs to step up to the plate and and
support the president's and the vice
president's aims of giving aid directly
to these persecuted minorities like this
and quite frankly and miss Shay's she
had a great op-ed with Fox News which I
read just just just today and was
talking about a school and telling us
God where the decently Christian to get
on this and that if the government is
working against the wishes David of the
administration the bureaucrats inside
the government
I saw it during the Reagan
administration all those years ago when
the State Department was working against
Raymond that is completely insubordinate
and they're just running their own mini
government inside our government you
can't support that I of course do not
support that and that should not be
happening but there's some strange thing
about what vice president Pence tried to
do he tried to say we need to move our
funding for refugees from the UN to
USAID but at the same time the
administration has proposed huge cuts to
USAID 27 percent cuts over the next ten
years so how has USAID going to do more
for Refugees when it has less that makes
no sense
but the bigger problem in Iraq which
people have to understand is the
administration support for one Iraq
policy rather than allowing Christians
and other minorities and have more power
as a designer ox is requisite disaster
should never contact Trump that's part
of the reason why I'm not a funding
problem here
we gave 32 million dollars to the Ringo
Muslims just two months ago as we should
have
yeah we're helping we're helping people
who need help but these Christians are
among the most persecuted in the is it
ease as well that's a great conversation
and don't know just talking about it
congressman I'm so sorry we'll have you
back well I'm gonna be on this issue for
years so thank you so much